it was supposed to be the summit that
would stop global warming but now
there's deep disappointment with
environmentalists saying cop 26 fell far
short of the urgent action that's needed
negotiations in glasgow went on beyond
the deadline as draft after draft came
closer to producing a global agreement
to restrict greenhouse gases but the
final document was met with anger after
india scuppered its key provision to
phase out coal power
the cobb 26 summit began with hopes to
save the planet and ended with an
apology
i apologize for
the way this process has unfolded
and
i'm deeply sorry
i also understand the the deep
disappointment
but i think as you have noted
it's also vital that we
protect this package
delegates did manage to come to an
agreement at the end of the conference
which has been seen as a final hour
last-ditch effort to stop catastrophic
climate change
most countries agreed on new and more
ambitious targets for reducing emissions
but the pledges fell short of what
science says is needed to stop the world
from heating beyond a dangerous 1.5
degrees celsius
india insisted on a last minute watering
down of the final text changing
references of a coal phase out to a
phase down
and wealthy nations resisted calls to
create a mechanism to compensate poor
countries suffering the worst effects of
climate change
un secretary general antonio guterres
urged countries to do more
as i said at the opening we must
accelerate action to keep the 1.5 degree
goal alive
our fragile planet is hanging by a
thread we are still knocking on the door
of climate catastrophe
it's time to go into emergency mode
or our chance of reaching net zero will
itself be zero
leaders agreed to reconvene for talks in
egypt next year where major emitters
will be asked to present new targets
but with the goal of 1.5 degrees now on
life support activists say cop 27 is
already dead
well deepai and basu ray climate
engagement initiative lead at climate
outreach is joining me now from oxford
in the united kingdom welcome to dw now
you were in glasgow following the
negotiations how disappointed are you
with this agreement
um i mean i think look at the at the
very outset uh the there's kind of the
main point is that this is a this is a
negotiation of of what 197 countries
uh no one you know one of the
delegations one of the southern
delegations said to me no one country
will ever get everything that they want
um
it does however feel very much like a
number of compromises were made in good
faith uh but they weren't reciprocated
with with uh with with similar good
faith on the other sides um so i think
we're all uh disappointed in the lack of
ambition especially as we started the
conference with so many calls
um for high ambition um so i think
there's still an awful lot of work to be
done you know i mean
we've not yet reached the point of
congratulating ourselves on on on on
anything really we've still got all of
the work still to do
diploma how is it possible that the
agreement on coal was watered down
at so last minute
i think there's a couple of points here
um to keep in mind uh and and you know
this links back to the work that climate
outreach does on on kind of public
engagement
um on the actual issue of the watering
down um let's look at it in in it's in
its entirety the there is a phasing down
of coal
yes which is not at all what we would
have uh what what the world needs to
achieve a 1.5 degree world um but the
text around fossil fuels was even more
dubious which was simply
of of of looking to cut out inefficient
subsidies not cutting down
on fossil fuels but cutting down on
inefficient subsidies so there's a lot
of word playing and a lot of gaming
being done by all uh you know all of the
bigger emitters um who are
at the table here and it's very easy to
point fingers at countries like india
and china
because the vast majority of their
energy
sources or rather a large portion of
their energy sources comes from coal
whereas we in the west
are the biggest emitters through fossil
fuels so it's very easy to say well it's
because of this and it's because of this
but there's been a lot of linguistic
gymnastics here uh and and i think the
the the blame needs to be understood in
a much more
uh nuanced way
uh tell me what does the glasgow climate
pact now mean for your future work
um well so i mean i think one thing is
it has been very clear is that
governments particularly those in the in
the in the bigger emitter countries
uh turned up with a set of policies um
that is not necessarily in line with how
their public
views action on climate uh engagement
and and on how climate uh issues need to
be dealt with um and and that is the
work that climate outreach has been
doing consistently for the last uh two
decades which is to try and make sure
and and to engage the public on these
issues you know all of the polls that
are coming out um certainly here in the
uk in the u.s and so on there is an
increased um understanding of of what
climate change is and people are are are
anxious to make
the right changes um in in in their
lives and lifestyles but they don't feel
connected to the policy-making process
so there is a real kind of need for
engagement uh government engagement with
the public on on both sensitizing and
learning and co-creating the solutions
that we need to reach the 1.5 world
dipayan basu ray climate engagement
initiative lead at climate outreach
thank you for joining us on dw today
thank you very much
all right for some analysis on this i'm
joined now by dw correspondent namisha
jaiswal in delhi hi namisha good to see
you now india openly tried to water down
this uh coal resolution did the indian
government get what it wanted in the end
though
well pablo from the indian perspective
it's not so much about simply getting
what it wants but forcing developed
countries to commit to what they owe to
the rest of the world india has insisted
that they are making commitments despite
serious developmental challenges prime
minister narendra modi in his speech
said that india will cut down emissions
it will cut to net zero emissions by
2070 and convert to renewable sources of
energy half of its energy by 2030 india
says that this shows its commitment to
mitigating climate change despite the
challenges it faces as a developing
country but it is entitled to
responsible use of coal which is why the
language watering down was pushed for
right now rich nations have been
reluctant to agree any mechanism to
provide funding for loss and damage what
does that mean for india
well this is definitely caused and
contributed to a trust deficit
especially when the hundred billion
dollar commitment to mitigate climate
change in developing countries was
missed in 2020 india insists that
develop developed countries grew as a
consequence of their heavy reliance on
coal and that these developing countries
understanding with climate changes
should be allowed to use coal
responsibly simply put it's a case of
alleging that the developed countries
are having their cake and eating it too
that they grew over 70 or 80 years
depending on coal but now are insisting
that india and other developing
countries need to be doing more by
committing to cuts in carbon emissions
and this is causing the resentment and
pushback that we're seeing however india
insists that it's doing more than it can
by committing to these goals
we're seeing some images there on the
screen of uh some of the pollution in
india how how urgent is it for india
though to do more than what's been
agreed on in the glasgow climate pact
well that's right pablo nobody can say
that india is not facing the
consequences of climate change i'm
sitting here in delhi and feeling a
trickle in my throat because my air
purifier is not on we've seen extreme
climatic events around the country
floods and cyclones
there's not only loss of life and
property but there could also be
potential loss of land as land is
getting submerged as a consequence of
climate change by some estimates if we
miss the 1.5 degree coal even in cities
like delhi being outside for three or
four hours as time as the temperature
increases could prove to be fatal so
there are definitely consequences that
the indian population could face however
the indian government almost has to
negotiate a trade-off india has suffered
massively consequence of coronavirus
lockdowns and it's a question of can we
trade how much of today can we trade for
the future
let me show you as well ian delhi thank
you